so Peter this you may have had your
reservations about intervening in Syria
about your rack first time round but
surely this is a fairly clear-cut
humanitarian case there are people being
crucified there are people starving up a
mountain we've got the mechanism to help
them do we not also have the moral
obligation to help them well first of
all do we have the mechanism to help
them in us so what is it
secondly what form would help take you
might be able to get them out of danger
possibly I'm not sure whether we even
have the forces that can do that but we
must remember that a year ago we were
seriously considering intervening on the
side of the people who now call
themselves Isis as it doesn't suggest we
have any very clear idea of what we're
doing in the area or that we have any
control over the long-term consequences
so I think we've had to be very careful
about what we said we were doing no
one's going to oppose sending succor to
the Yazidis or indeed the the Iraqi or
Syrian Christians who have menaced by
these people and it is trying to get
them away from their persecutors but
beyond that I think we have to be
extremely careful what we consider doing
and also we have to be extremely modest
about what we think we can do don't Liz
what do you think we can do and what do
you think we should do well I mean I
think there's certainly no doubt that
there is a lack of strategic thinking
from this country now there's about
exactly what it is we expect or might
hope to see or might be able to help
create in the region however even that
that being said that lack of initiative
undoubtedly being there there is this
question of what in the immediate term
one might be able to do and I think I
think that the the ability to at the
very least send humanitarian assistance
to the CDs and others we're doing that
already interact with doing already and
if necessary to help push back Isis from
their doorstep now that is that's the
problematic one because we might get
back into that position of a kind of
whack-a-mole there are things that are
worse than a whack-a-mole of course we
such as Isis effectively sort of winning
but I think there should be some clear
idea of what pushing them back means
we're pushing them back to a
is the aim none of that is clear at the
moment but I think that there is a just
cause that just desire to try to stop
Isis getting any further better you will
agree I'm sure that the ISIS do pose an
appalling threat to to the region they
are not in the business simply of
occupying territory but of killing women
children they're talking people being
and buried alive now
isn't this the very an example of what
the United Nations calls a
responsibility to protect I mean there
if we see a massacre about to happen
there is surely an obligation to the
West to stop it and you asked what we
could do but we can go and take for
example we can take them down from that
we can do repeated sorties help taking
down from the mountain where they're
about to die into safety these are
things which doesn't don't involve our
being entangled there for long time well
that's reasonable in itself if that's
all you do and if this isn't being used
as a pretext for a reengagement in Iraq
from which some Americans particularly
feel they were wrongly expelled by the
Iraqi government and they would like a
pretext to go back then are we going to
get involved in defending Kurdistan and
actually becoming in effect the army of
Kurdistan and a country which we've
created that won't acknowledge we have
created and therefore will not arm but
with with the sort of modern weapons we
gave to Iraq because we still pretend
that we can maintain the unity of Iraq
in face of the fact that it's really
three countries Kurdistan the sheer Iraq
and the Sunni Iraq I don't go there are
all incredibly complicated things going
on here its degree than what one is one
step very rapidly needs to another and
once the danger is that you the what is
being offered is not a an intervention
with a specific limited purpose with an
intervention which is open-ended and
which will go on for a very long time
will have huge unintended consequences
as previous interventions have also we
have to be sure that the information
we're getting about what's going on is
correct and we have to understand what
Isis is and Isis is fundamentally an
outgrowth of
war between Saudi Arabia and Iran which
is now really the dominant problem in
the Middle East which we have
contributed to you mentioned that we
created Kurdistan I mean we did that
through Operation Desert Fox in the
aftermath of the first Gulf War were the
British enforced no-fly zone which
created an area of incredible peace and
prosperity had to be backed up with with
troops on the ground
sure birds I would point to Kurdistan as
an example of where British intervention
can actually help and lead to prosperity
is God's quite a long track right up to
a point but are we actually prepared to
become the army of Kurdistan which is
showing soph perhaps on equals the task
for defending itself against Isis is
that what we're going to do and how far
do we get involved in that if we
actually do create a Kurdistan and break
up Iraq something which we claim is the
kind of thing we don't do we're changing
the whole political and economic
geography of the Middle East is this
what we're getting involved in and if so
do we really imagine it'll be over by
the fall of the leaves I say I'm not
sure it's going to be the case of this
country had it in its power even if we
wish do to do as it were break up a
right or create a Curtis not know I
agree with that but I think what we
anything that we would contemplate of
necessity since this government is
pretty much dismantled our armed forces
would would be piggybacking if on
American power anyway and would be for
political cover purposes rather than
because we were actually necessary to
the operation and that's a question of
whether we wish to give political cover
to and be stuck bodily inside such an
operation I mean there is if I said
there is a striking thing about the
Kurdistan example but which is a the
argument for them staying in Iraq since
2003 was that they had had a ten-year
head start on the rest of the country
that they had they had liberalize
modernized democratized to an extent and
so on and they would be a effectively of
good influence in the new Iraq I do
think that that argument is taking a
huge blow in recent months but for
anything else it is very hard if the
Kurds decide to really make a move for
breakaway it's very hard to argue
against it now since it's clear the rest
of the country security interests are
not their security interests which is
complicated for us in our argument with
Russia
at the moment if we start saying that
breakaways are okay then the the Ottawa
Kosovo is complicated but there but if
we then allow for a breakaway in
Kurdistan then we are altering the
borders of the world in a way which we
say we're against but the the other the
other point here is that if we break up
Iraq then we have admitted the complete
failure of our previous mission to admit
also that Isis or whatever it's called
this week is a major threat is to cast
enormous doubt on our services not maybe
a year ago when we were talking about
air attacks on Syria but before that
when we were taking part in the
destabilization of Syria whose
government is now one of the principal
Bork's against Isis we have made the
most tremendous mess of this all the
people like me are saying is that we
should acknowledge that we have got it
repeatedly wrong in the past we should
be very careful about what we commit
ourselves to in the future I do agree
with one caveat which is that I mean the
the disaster of Syria is not our fault
yes it is we Claire are there it is the
fault of the actors involved in
particular the actors in the region that
have decided to use Syria as a proxy
battleground we the West Britain in
particular are really a no player at all
in Syria and never really have been over
the years of the Civil War the main
players in Syria or Iran and Saudi well
no there was a very strong impression
given by the United States and France
and Britain that we were on the side of
a rebellion against against Bashar Assad
and it was that impression which I think
led to the loss of the advances made by
the rebels in the earlier
period before the question of arming
them and joining in on their side had
arisen so I think we should we should be
careful to recognize that we did play
some part in that so your position be do
it effectively is that and as we've seen
in Iraq and Afghanistan these things
always go wrong so we shouldn't even try
humanitarian mission no I'm saying those
all I would never be against
humanitarian missions provided that
that's what they are and provided their
their effective be crazy to be against
humanitarian missions but to be very
very careful to be sure that that is all
that we are doing